Good news.
We all have a new brain cell.
And it’s looking like this particular kind
of brain cell could be unique to humans!.
Do you feel smarter yet?
Well you’re about to, ‘cause we’re gonna
talk about your brain.
Which, it turns out, science actually knows
very little about.
We’re JUST starting to scratch the surface,
and mapping the brain is a far greater challenge
even than mapping the human genome.
But let’s go over some basics:
Your brain is full of cells: neurons, and
glia.
We’re going to focus mostly on neurons,
which are the messengers of information.
Neurons communicate with each other and with
the rest of your nervous system through electrical
and chemical signals, and are supported by
glial cells.
There are three main kinds of neurons: sensory
neurons, which communicate information from
your senses to your brain; motor neurons,
which help you control your body’s movements,
and interneurons, which help motor neurons
and sensory neurons talk to each other.
Within these categories, neurons can be either
excitatory or inhibitory.
As their names suggest, excitatory neurons
pass information along to other neurons, while
inhibitory neurons can slow down excitatory
action and stop other neurons from firing,
controlling the flow of information in the
brain.
And the big news is that we’ve found a new
kind of interneuron, called the rosehip cell--sittin’
right there in this vast, unknown universe
that lives inside our own heads.
What’s particularly exciting about this
new research is that scientists are starting
to use novel methods to delve into the brain.
Recent advances in RNA analysis techniques
called transcriptomics allow to see more detail
than ever before about how the brain works.
A group at the Allen Institute for Brain Science
in Seattle used these RNA sequencing techniques
to identify unique gene expression patterns
in frozen brain tissue.
Meanwhile, a partner research team in Hungary
used more traditional slice and dice lab imaging
techniques--on live brain tissue taken from
brain surgery patients--to see evidence of
a cell that matched the genetic markers found
by the Seattle group.
Ta da--brand new brain cell type, observed.
So how does it affect human behavior?
We’re not quite sure.
Yet.
The rosehip neuron appears to act as an inhibitory
neuron.
It’s called the rosehip neuron because it
looks like the plant, and its specialized
shape, with rosehip-like bulges on its axons
may help it act on the brain in a particular
way.
Lots more research is needed to discover the
effect of rosehip neurons on human behavior
and cognition, but there are early hopes that,
as a neuron that controls information flow
in the brain, it could be a key part of understanding
intellectual disability and neuropsychiatric
diseases like schizophrenia.
Perhaps the most important part of this discovery
though is that so far, we haven’t been able
to find the same kind of brain cell in the
mouse brain.
We rely on mice to study everything from cancer
to pharmaceutical development to alzheimer’s,
so this lack of an analogous structure in
the rodent brain highlights how different
the two really are.
This discovery in particular points out important
gaps that may result from trying to study
human brain function in mouse models.
We’re making valuable progress in the vast
unknown frontier of our brains, but there’s
still a heck-of-a long way to go.
Does your brain hurt from all the knowledge?
Subscribe to Seeker so we can guide you through
all the brain learnin’.
And fun fact, there’s a project in the US
called the BRAIN Initiative, which stands
for Brain Research through Advancing Innovative
Neurotechnologies, and is dedicated to improving
our understanding of the human brain.
Thanks for watching.